this is a statue of Nandi kanu with its
arms chopped off the real Namba Kanu has
disappeared
eyewitnesses say security forces stormed
his house in southeastern Nigeria and
September he has not been seen since the
army says he fled but this man believes
he was killed
Cucina physique as a member of the
separatist IPO be the indigenous people
of Biafra he has been on guard at his
leaders house since it was raided and
Kanu himself disappeared the thought
from that join shown there the digestion
of idea that we referred a shooting the
contact here so most of what was wrong
aware that someone like me ran away some
of the separatists filmed what they
believe was a military operation
Ubah zika says that 20 people were
killed that afternoon the brother of the
missing separatist leader went
underground
after many unsuccessful attempts to
contact him he agreed to meet us
he says the actions of the Nigerian
military has made the IPO be even more
determined to carry on asking for
referendum is not asking for war want to
be three people and only welcomed
achieve that is true referendum and
that's what everyone believes in today
the government has rejected the
separatists demands it says an
independence referendum would be
unconstitutional and dangerous the
information minister says all the
governors in the region are of the same
opinion they are conscious of their
responsibility to the people and they
are not going to be encouraging any kind
of agitation that leads to loss of lives
fear of an escalating conflict is
growing among the population Nigerians
in the southeast of the country have
long felt sidelined and neglected but
many do not sympathize with a radical
approach of the via foreign separatists
there's an increasingly harsh exchange
of words on both sides of the conflict
some supporters of an independent Biafra
speak about the destruction of Nigeria
the government on the other side calls
the separatist movement a terrorist
organization most observers doubt that
in the current political climate a
peaceful referendum would be possible
the memory of the be a foreign war 50
years ago is still fresh here the last
time the region tried to break away from
Nigeria more than a million people lost
their lives back then John Columbus
fought on the side of the separatists he
still gets together with his old
comrades to discuss the current
political situation the veterans are
worried about the risks of holding a
referendum too early
they've been keenly watching similar
developments in other parts of the world
what Nigeria can borrow from Spain now
is that the referendum can be stopped
the footing can be stopped and a prophet
and that anything can happen these
veterans are holding on to their dream
of an independent fee opera but not at
any price the tools of war they say must
stay where they belong in a museum